faty vie à mantes la jolie elle sera
dimanche au départ du cyclo-défi
qu'organise l'association solidarité
handicap france cameroun avant d'avaler
des kilomètres de routes
il lui faut d'abord apprendre à réparer
engrais tt bonjour faty comment tu vas
c'est va bien on va t'expliquer un petit
peu comment est ce que tu peux faire
pour entretenir pour mon ton vélo avant
de partir en randonnée comme tu prépares
le le tour des yvelines avec tous tes
petits copains la semaine prochaine à
travers le vélo l'association veut
permettre aux jeunes yvelinois de
quartiers prioritaires situés notamment
à elancourt et guyancourt de prendre en
main un projet d'être responsables de
leur destin
alors aujourd'hui on a appris quelques
règles de sécurité à faty un déjà de
vérifier de savoir enlever sa enlever sa
roue et la remettre de bien vérifier
qu'elles soient bien serré à réparer une
chambre à air c'est ce qui arrive le
prime plus fréquemment c2c de crever une
formule que sidonie et bonga
coordinatrice de l'événement a importé
du canada s'émanciper grâce au sport le
concept là tout de suite séduite
il permet aux participants de sortir de
leurs
environnement quotidien et d'aller
découvrir le département en profondeur
culturellement économiquement
géographiquement l'enjeu n'est pas
seulement d'apporter du bien-être aux
jeunes mais aussi de changer les
représentations vis-à-vis des banlieues
l'ambition donner une image aussi des
jeunes du quartier prioritaire qui soit
non seulement celle des casseurs des
pires doodle une époque mais celle aussi
des jeunes qui veulent s'intégrer à ce
jour la course compte une trentaine de
participants et il est toujours possible
de s'inscrire
si le succès est au rendez vous
l'événement sera reconduit l'an prochain
[Musique]